mademoiselle mademoiselle s'il vous
plaît mademoiselle manoise mademoiselle
ses démons c'est dingue dingue dingue
dingue ses démons dément dément dément
démantèlement c'est de pire en pire ça
s'aggrave tous les jours et personne
n'en parle
et bien moi je dis halte stop ça suffit
comme ça basta cosi moi je vais le dire
hein c'est pas grave mais si on veut
guérir le mal il faut le mettre au grand
jour
moi je vais le dire il n'ya plus d'amour
en france surtout chez les femmes
ah je sais ça fait mal ça fait très mal
mais c'est la vérité
et moi qui voyage beaucoup à l'étranger
je sais de quoi je parle
bon déjà lorsque je travaillais en
france je m'étais bien aperçu que de ce
côté là du côté des femmes
il y avait quelque chose qui clochait
des choses que l'on peut vous lancer non
ou alors c'est à vous tous ça touche pas
à salo voyeur
les signes avant-coureurs du mal si vous
voulez mais je me disais bon elles sont
en crise est une période sa valeur
passée mais depuis que je voyage à
l'étranger pour mon travail
là je suis formelle il n'y a plus
d'amour en france surtout chez les
femmes
ainsi les femmes de france de sa fumée
c'est sûr tenez un exemple sans aller
chercher le bout du monde
l'autre jour j'étais à evian france
je marchais vers les 10 11 heures du
soir sur les rives du lac à l'oeuvre la
lune la brume le lac une bonne douzaine
de grenouilles
oh oui enfin tout pour le sentiment quoi
inopinément je croise une jeune fille
blonde en jean qui marchait d'un pas vif
mais alerte et dans ce merveilleux
paysages je m'approche d'elle soir alors
on se promène bon écoute max jumelage
parce que moi je sors de l'usiné était
déco non j'ai pas que ça à m'envoyer à
voilà la femme française on ne parle que
boulot alors que le lendemain à la même
heure avec la même l'une la même brume
mais de l'autre côté
en suisse pas en france je croise une
jeune personne superbe grande brune un
très joli petit sac
m
les petits sacs habillé tout en panthère
non mais déjà rien que ça ça montre un
effort pour plaire un oui c'est pas le
jean délavé et ben appel j'allais lui
adresser la parole qu'elle me dit tu
prends un verre je n'invente rien la
même l'une la même brume le même lac
mais pas en france c'est tout parce
qu'en france il n'y a pas d'amour
surtout chez les femmes et pour ne me
dise pas que ça vient moi un que je ne
fais pas d'effort que je me désintéresse
faux pas à moi non messieurs
tenez encore la semaine dernière j'ai
consacré un samedi entier aux jeunes
françaises j'étais assis à la terrasse
du café de la paix et bien si je n'ai
pas proposé à dix jeunes filles de venir
au cinéma avec moi je n'ai pas proposé à
une va te faire [ __ ]
connard
c'était leur grand mot ah non non ils
vont mal elles vont mal très très mal
bon tout n'est pas foutu c'est vrai pari
n'est tout de même pas le désert
intégrale de l'amour c'est vrai moi même
l'autre jour en passant rue saint denis
j'ai eu une petite aventure où une jeune
fille charmante au demeurant enfin rien
de bien sérieux moss aurait pu être une
liaison si j'avais voulu un et bien vous
me croirez si vous voulez elle n'était
pas française c'est quand même
malheureux que ce soit les étrangères
qui donne l'exemple
alors après on se plaint que les
touristes ne viennent plus en france
allez petite femme les petites femmes
les petites femmes de paris oui eh ben
non elles sont pas de paris elles sont
chez eux alors ils restent chez eux
non non non
quand je pense à toutes ces filles qui
savait mais qui ont le coeur sous la
main bangkok mexico hambourg
tenez encore il ya un mois à athènes
cette petite femme de chambre que j'ai
retrouvé dans mon lit amoureuse et si
merveilleusement tendre qui non
seulement m'a donné de l'amour pendant
toute une nuit
mais aussi m'a donné le bonheur de
pouvoir aider les miséreux les la la
joie si la joie que j'ai eue le matin en
lui donnant les 2500 francs 2500 francs
qu'elle me demandait pour sa vieille
mère qui vivait depuis près de 50 ans
dans une grotte sans eau ni électricité
c'était une joie infinie merci mélina
non vraiment par moment moi franchement
j'ai envie de tout larguer et d'aller
m'installer là-bas à l'étranger
seulement aussi des types comme moi
quitte définitivement la france y aura
plus jamais d'amour en france surtout
chez les femmes alors c'est pour ça
j'essaye encore je me balade
mademoiselle mademoiselle
qu'est ce que vous faites à midi mais
alors à 6 heures ben vous ce soir et
demain